You are listening to radio lab radio lab
from [inaudible], w.
N y. S. C. E. N. N. P. R.
Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert
Krulwich, Radiolab, the podcast,
and today on the podcast, something
from our producer, Sean Cole.
You've been out doing something.
I've been doing many things,
but I mean in particular with regard to
this podcast, you have a story for us.
I do. Don't tell us about this
other thing. Nope. What's his story?
So this is a story about a woman.
You've probably seen her. Really?
You've seen her face. Oh,
you may have even dated her.
We'll put your mouth on her to explain.
So you know when you got to bring
somebody back to life. One, two, three.
Hold on, let me come take a class. Yep.
And they make you practice
on this dummy CPR.
The dummy has this face that you
suck on. Well, you don't suck on it.
You blow into us. When I met you don't
know a lot about CPR. Yeah, right. Well,
what's the story with the dog?
Shoot was so, so that lady,
we're nine 30 before she was a dummy.
That face belonged to
an actual woman's face,
CPR dummies faces and actual an actual
lady that was transfixing and inspiring
to millions of people and
used to basically hang out
with Napoleon and Mozart.
True. Yes. I first heard this
story from this guy, Jeremy Grange.
I'm a producer with BBC radio in the UK.
He made it a documentary about
all of this, well a while back,
but basically we story starts.
Our story starts in Norway.
In the early 1950s there was this toy
maker named Osman, the layer doll,
and last month lay Adele was making
plastic toys, brightly colored toys,
and their story also involves
his two year old son. Ta-Da.
I'm the Torah LADOT. He's
all grown up. Now what?
Obviously I don't recall
the details myself,
but it's being told to me that
one day he and his father,
Osmond victim are at their summer home,
which is on the ocean and somehow tore
toddles is way out of sight and the next
thing anyone knows,
the OSI was found floating
face down and the C
and a I was just kept floating by
some air trapped in a rain coat.
He's on top of a raincoat on
the water. So I think the,
I think the raincoat is on top of him,
but basically it's keeping him a lot.
So there's a bubble of air under.
Yeah. And then Osman, his dad sees him.
I don't know how long I
have been in the water,
but when I was pulled out by
my father, I was life, uh,
less.
And not only does Asman not know
mouth to mouth resuscitation,
this was in 1954.
There is no mouth to mouth
resuscitation. I mean, no,
people didn't know about it. It
hadn't really been developed yet.
And so his dad, they was shaking
me on doing whatever he could.
Gradually I responded and as fate would
have it, not long after that, Osmond,
I mean freshly saved,
a son from drowning is contacted by the
man who is developing mouth to mouth
resuscitation. An Austrian
doctor called Peter Safer,
a good name for a guy
trying to keep people safer.
We'd worked out all the basics of
CPR with the mouth to mouth and the
compressing the chest
and everything like that.
But he realized he needed a way
for people to practice this.
And my father was asked whether he
possibly could help making some kind of
training device. And pretty
quickly, Osman thought, well,
we need the dummy and the
mannequins. Somewhere along the line,
Aspen had to decide what the face
of this dummy was gonna look like.
Yeah.
Should it be a woman? Should it be a man?
I think you felt that
people would be more, um,
intimidated or shy or
if it was a man's face.
So he decided to go with a woman's face
and attractive woman's face because at
that time you were asking lay people to
blow into the quote unquote dead person.
You know, you don't want to blow into
somebody who's gaping with a horror face.
She should, she should look
comfortably dead. And then the, uh,
came across this, uh, um,
girl in my grandparents' home asthma and
is there in the house and he looks up
at the wall and sees this face of a woman.
It's a mask.
And my father was taken back by the
beauty of this face and he says,
that's the face. That's the face.
I'll use this as a mass as what kind
of mask was this? It was a death mask.
What's the death mask? All
right, I'm going to get,
I'm going to go back even further
here. So stay with me for a minute.
Back in the 19th century, commonly
people after they were dead,
they'd have masks made of their
faces. Here's one of Abraham Lincoln.
There's a death deathmatch.
Really? Yeah, cause you want,
you want to preserve their countenance.
So right after the person dies,
pretty much you take a bunch of clay and
you stick it on their face and you make
a mold, fill the mold with plaster
and then you've got a plaster masking.
You can reproduce it and reproduce
it. It was especially common in Paris.
Hey Radiolab. It is a sunny,
cold Paris October morning
and weeks, months makers,
workshops that existed
around Paris 120 years ago.
There's only one left nor about to
visit. Cool. Lorenzi is, which is a,
which is it like a mass making
shops. So coming up to the gate,
we asked our friends, Kristin Clark,
and tomorrow's Red Dorevitch
to drop by there for us.
I've still got this incredible workshop
and you go up some rickety narrow wooden
stairs
and you get to the top and there's just
level pranks of faces or rows and rows
of people that look like they're sleeping.
Death mosques of who is
the one at the top there?
Everybody Know Napoleon and bullion
here where the rope spear Hovis.
He was in the French
mucked sauce and Beethoven.
It's the mask of shopper.
The composer looking at you from
the wall and from the ceiling.
All of their eyes are closed
face after face after face.
And there are famous historical figures,
but also among them is this girl.
Oh,
she is not a poet. She's not
a conqueror's. Not Anybody.
[inaudible]
which has gotta be somebody.
I mean who, who? Well,
the story that emerged after she died
in, this is possibly fancy, possibly,
you know, maybe fact, but
the sources are lost to us.
So we were not sure exactly what happened,
but she was young in her early
to mid twenties who, you know,
came from the countryside,
not from Paris, you know,
she was a sort of poor, uneducated
woman, but she came to Paris,
meets a man and there was a love affair,
which then turns sour
the stories that may be she was pregnant
and abandoned or maybe she was just
abandoned.
She goes to a bridge that's
stretching across the same,
might be the one by the loo
steps to the edge and she
threw herself into the river
and he drowned and then
the body was recovered.
She was taken to the morgue,
which wasn't that far away.
And in those days police would be
displayed behind glass and hopefully their
relatives or their friends
would come along and say, yes,
that's my father or my
sister or my daughter.
And they would reclaim the bodies
since they were displayed.
We're also like strangers coming around
for a kind of like weird Museumy,
um, thrill that. Absolutely, yes it was.
That's probably what it was with her.
She was a particularly beautiful co-ops
and everybody rushed down to see her.
And eventually the,
the guy who ran the morgue took a plaster
cast of her face because she was so
beautiful. He was just struck
by her, just like layer it all,
just like everybody.
What'd she look like? Yeah,
I wouldn't say sort of plump face
around it face. She's lovely,
but not in a come hither way.
She's more like sort of weirdly
saintly looking like she's serene,
innocent, serene, innocent,
but also sort of knowing
and she has a little smile.
If you look at the master,
there's just this little smile playing
on the lips and it's just enough to kind
of make you think, well, why
is she smiling and who is she?
And the problem was if wasn't
identified, oh, so they didn't know. No.
And so ultimately people started
calling her by this name,
the [inaudible]. Um, can you,
well, so you know, like the word
Ingenue, which means innocent lady like,
or the character of the
ingenue, the movies. This is
long canoe, which means unknown. And
can you tell us the unknown woman,
uh, of the scene? And
then gradually the, uh,
plastic cost worked its way into the mask
makers workshops and now it's onto the
streets of Paris.
And it wasn't long before this woman
became a sensation and everyone started
writing about her,
the face of the young drunk woman real
cause beautiful because it's mild smiled
so deceptively as though it view a Niacin
in the woman who had drawn a self here
years ago and who is so
beautiful that's Nabokov,
touchingly frail young shoulders who
wrote this entire poem sort of demanding,
you know, who made you
jump? Who was he? You know,
who was the guy that'd be [inaudible]
tell me your mysterious seducer.
Was He some neighbors? Curly locked nephew
of the loud tie and gold capped too.
In any case, this mask is a
huge deal in all thousands.
Countless people have it hanging on
their wall the same way you would hang
Napoleon on your wall because he's
Napoleon, but they don't know who she is.
And that's sort of the point.
They're like, who is she?
And everybody's captivated, including
our toy maker, a small layer doe.
He felt that the [inaudible] canoe,
the attractiveness and the story would
be the right model to use for the first
CPR mannequin in history.
Who has a name crystal CN resusci n could
you describe what we have in front of
us here? What we see
is the very first, uh,
production muddled. I'll recess the
album from 1968. She's had to check.
The face has changed slightly
because if you want to do CPR,
you have to have an open
mouth. So regrettably,
the slight smile is now imparted,
but you've still got the high
forehead and the closed eyes.
And I'm every went through the
[inaudible] CPR mannequin that's produced.
300 million people have been trained on
this thing since it was first introduced
in 1968. And every single dummy
has the face of the encore,
new still stiller. And um, hopefully
she's looking quite attractive. Four six,
seven, eight, nine,
10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15,
16, 17, 18.
Craziest part about it is that this
face of this wound woman nine 30,
becomes the face that people blow into
to learn how to save drowned people.
It's like, it's like over
and over and over again.
Thousands and thousands of people
are trying to bring
this woman back to life.
That's kind of beautiful. [inaudible]
issue. Maybe like it's like it'd be fact.
You've just given her isn't
really a given about her. Actually
no about this, this
woman. Well, so I mean,
Jeremy went into his research
sort of asking the same question,
what do we really know? What
we really know what's true?
I, uh, I have a horrible
suspicion. The truth, you know,
is that she didn't die. Yeah. I mean,
having shown the mask to
Pascal's your account,
who's a member of the BRCA and fluvial
this is the river police whose job it
is to pull dead bodies out of the sane
rescue people from the sane.
And Pascal is in charge. So
whoa, you know, hundreds
of have drowned bodies. Uh,
he can look at a face and he can know
whether that's somebody who's drowned.
And he said it's surprising
when I saw the picture to, to,
to see that so peaceful
face just because, uh,
everyone we found in the water is never
are so peaceful and not to put too fine
a point on it, but when somebody drowned,
they start decomposing quite quickly.
They are swollen most of the times or
the features that you have seen in life
don't really last very long.
It's not so nice looking once
somebody who's been in the water.
Do you think she's attractive? Yeah.
Yes, of course. Yeah. Yeah. Just,
she looks very regretful.
So if she didn't die
then who was she then?
She may have been a model that
somebody just thought was pretty,
wanted to take a plaster
cast for her face.
I facing Munis really at that
point it's, it's anybody's guess.
We don't know this,
this is our end of knowing her
and knowing what's frustrating,
but maybe it's better that way.
I mean, if you don't like the,
the reason why she was so captivating is
because people don't know and they can
just feel this gap with their own stories
that can just sort of sit there and
muse a better. In fact, uh, Jeremy, uh,
told me this story about this
museum that he went to in Liverpool.
It was the historic house
of a photographer there
[inaudible] in the kind of
waiting room, the walls,
the mask of the ankle knew
actually on the wall there.
So you know, slightly disingenuously
I asked the Guide, Oh,
what's that? Very disingenuine. Well
then you knew everything about it.
At that point I thought, I thought
I'd see, and it was amazing.
She told me this story about twins, two,
two girls from Liverpool,
and this is the important bit from where
we were from the city where we weren't,
not from no from anywhere.
The story was almost exactly the same
except this time one of the twin girls
left Liverpool in her late teens or
early twenties, made her way to Paris,
fell in love, got
knocked up. The guy left,
she despaired and then [inaudible] off
the bridge and drowned and the mosque of
this beautiful corpse was taken. But
this, this version keeps going after that,
50 years later,
the surviving twin who never
knew what happened to her sister,
takes a trip to Paris
walking through the streets of Paris
and sees this face on the wall and yeah,
this time, instead of
it being her own faith,
it's the face of her twin
sister who's there. And,
and so her twin who,
who died long before her is kind
of kept forever young. Well,
she's had to hage and so she's from
Liverpool now as far as you know,
as far as the Liverpudlians
are concerned. Yeah.
And I wonder if she's also
from Cornwall as far as,
as far as the corn plants are
concerned and from, you know,
like maybe she's, um, a Moscow bite
as far as the people in Moscow,
she says Cillian as far as
the Sicilians are concerned,
maybe she's a Laotian as far as the
Laotians has been some kind of Buenos
already in Australia. Hello
cal cutten. As far as the
[inaudible], as far as the
bay routines are concerned,
just with [inaudible] school,
Dean Denver as [inaudible]
deletion [inaudible] in Dallas.
Pretty sure Sanko. And before we go,
thank you to Jeremy
Grange and to our readers,
Pike Melon Off Ski Marine
Gudo and Jeff Spurgeon,
and special thanks to be some
Morehouse and Michelle kind of.